[Music]
foreign
well hello there watching The Press
preview a first look at of course at
what is on the front pages time to see
what's making the headlines with for the
very first time the Daily Mail columnist
Sarah Vine and the associate editor at
the Daily Mirror Kev Maguire welcome
Sarah and uh great to see you back Kevin
more from both of you in just a moment
uh front pages though let us start with
the Metro grinner Barrett that's the
headline in the Metro as Jeremy Hunt
prepares to deliver a budget which would
start filling the 60 billion pound black
hole
the story also dominates the front of
the financial times as they write about
the Chancellor's aims to cut public
spending and raise taxes
Daily Telegraph quotes Jeremy Hunt
saying we will face into the storm as he
prepares to unveil 24 billion pounds in
tax Rises The Daily Express tells of how
Jeremy Hunt's fair and honest budget
will help whether the economic storm the
guardian reports on his plans to lift
price caps on energy bills affecting
billions of households while the times
shines a light on how tomorrow's budget
will impact the wealthy daily stars from
page highlights Donald Trump's hope to
plant the American flag on Mars and the
Daily Mail focuses on the rationing of
eggs in supermarkets amid the bird flu
and issue and the war in Ukraine
well reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and our guests so let's go to Sarah Vine
and Kevin McGuire who are with us to
look at what is a good set of papers I
suppose for anyone who's waiting to see
what's in the
um Autumn statement but Sarah let's look
at the Metro first of all uh grin and
bear had a picture of a smiling
Chancellor there with not a lot of cheer
to deliver one presumes oh yeah it's not
really a smile it's more of a Grimace
isn't it I mean he's got a really
difficult Balancing Act to try and pull
off tomorrow
um especially given the mess that Liz
trust made the last attempt to do some
sort of budget and I think that he I
mean you know the thing about Jeremy
Hunters that he he you know he's he
wasn't the Tori's First Choice probably
the for for Chancellor he's there
he's got there by a slightly roundabout
way and now he's sort of got the most
important job of the last I don't know
three years so it's a big moment for him
so what is the priority then Kevin I
mean calming the market was the initial
priority uh it's tackling inflation but
many on the right wing of the
conservative party are now talking about
the Real Enemy being recession
um so The Balancing Act is a genuine one
isn't it for the chancellor
no absolutely as he cuts spending and
raises uh taxes he can be trying to fill
in a hole is he still digging a Dipper
Bank of England said the recession could
be two years but not particularly
shallow well it could actually extend it
and make it deeper and I I look at that
front page on the Metro and I think it's
all wrong for Jeremy Hunt and Richie
sunac because grin and bear it is going
to be really Grim tomorrow and the Metro
notes that he managed to smile it's not
gonna be like that for families and
businesses that are going to be
clobbered so I think that mood is wrong
but I note the Metro accepts on
critically there is a 60 billion black
hole that black hole to some extent is
just an accounting method and if you
shift when uh the debt would fall as a
proportion of national wealth a few
years or calculated differently there
isn't a black hole at all like that but
they've they've accepted it uncritically
as I think we're going to see tomorrow a
lot of a lot of pain and they're going
to be saying look you've got to take it
uh but blame trust to some extent but
the problems we're in way before Tross
of the economy some of it inflicted by
brexit some of it by covert some of it
by the Russian invasion of Ukraine
Ukraine some of it the conservatives
doing things over the the last 12 years
uh just made it made it worse rather
than growing Britain well certainly the
governor of the bank of England talks
about waves of Supply shocks hitting the
UK economy you know the pandemic um you
know largely china-oriented I suppose uh
but also you know shipping containers in
the wrong place you name it all of that
supply chain issue there
um then of course the labor market
retracting not as many people in the
labor market and then of course the war
in Ukraine the massive impact on energy
and food prices which we've seen today
have we not Sarah inflation at uh you
know a 40 plus year High
um the financial times though um saying
Jeremy Hunt will seek to restore
Britain's tarnished economic reputation
with this massive pack of tax Rises and
spending cuts and certainly that was
also something that um Andrew Bailey
talked about today
yeah I mean I think the thing is that
there is a tarnish that the Tories have
a tarnished Financial reputation the
thing is the difficulty they have here
is that people have always relied on the
conservative party to be fiscally
responsible I mean traditionally Eric
Kevin will probably argue this with me
but traditionally it's been the labor
party have been profitable with money
and the sort of the sort of dynamic has
always been labor spends all the money
that the toys come in and then they fix
the big black hole in the finances and
then everything goes back to sort of
being okay
and they've totally deviated from that
um and yes you're right there's lots of
factors there's Ukraine there's Global
headwinds all this kind of stuff but the
bottom line for voters is that you know
this Administration
has got us in a real in a really
difficult financial situation and that
is the problem
yes I mean are you going back all the
way to austerity in this or are you
focusing on those trusts right right the
way back
I'm sort of going back all the way I
mean
you know when when the cam when Cameron
came in there was that famous note left
to the treasury you know sorry we've
spent all the money and there was a sort
of justification at that point for
austerity but the problem with they have
now is that after all Theseus in power
there's no justification really other
than you know
their own fiscal
not incompetence perhaps but
I know maybe incompetence is the word
but do you know what I mean it's it's
it's it that's the problem for the
tourists that's the real problem for the
Tories it politically and I think that's
what people are going to really struggle
with which is that you know they're
supposed to be the fiscal grown-ups and
this is not really what we're seeing the
the conservatives crushed the economy
specifically around the trust period of
the resolution Foundation says 30
billion that that cost that is Labor's
best attack line in decades because
there is a truth in it and people saw
that with their mortgages where the
mortgage Market was was wrecked the
pound plummeted in in value but
returning to the Astoria austerity of
2010 I think would be a mistake because
the tax Rises then and the spending cut
snuffed out a a promising recovery I put
it no more than a promise in recovery
and growth never really reached any
significant level over the over that
following decade and as a result debt
national debt is it was below it was
below um uh a trillion when the uh when
the concerns took over and it's over 2
trillion now I think it's 2.4 trillion
so just it just doesn't work but the the
Ft pick up one of the one of the
measures and it's very it's very ft-ish
but it may matter to us all is changing
the rules to allow Pension funds to
invest in green energy now that's how
that sounds great but the rules that
changing are are solvency rules which
are there to try and ensure Pension
funds don't go Belly Up don't go
bankrupt so it is something of a risky
it's a it's a gamble just gotta hope it
isn't a reckless gamble well many of the
newspapers including the Daily Telegraph
go through some of the specifics that we
can expect the paper saying that the
Autumn statement will include 30 billion
pounds of spending cuts although Mr Hunt
will pledge to support core public
services such as the NHS the article
also suggests it will protect schools
and the police as well he's also likely
to confirm benefits and state pensions
will rise in line with inflation but
what about those tax increases you know
clearly the you know the trust side to
the conservative party have been rather
bruised and quiet will there be
complaints do you think from uh the Tory
party itself about tax Rises suggestions
and Daily Telegraph Sarah 24 billion
pounds of tax increases equivalent to
860 pounds for every household in the
country is what we can expect
I mean tax and spend has always been
again a labor policy it's not a Tory
policy it's not what the conservatives
do the conservatives are all about
letting people keep more of their money
so they can make better decisions and
the thing about this Administration is
that
they've also got a situation where they
are being they're we're hemorrhaging
money in our Public Services you know if
you look at the NHS you know last week
there was a story about you know some
agency nurses being paid 2 000 pounds to
fill gaps that were in the Roses you
know we're throwing more money at the
French to not stop migrants Crossing uh
the channel there's a sense that you're
paying more and you're sort of getting
less and competence is getting worse so
I mean they're really they're they're in
a really tight Corner the conservatives
at the moment on this I think and I
think and I thought the 45p thing was
silly and and just such bad Optics I
just don't really understand how they
even contemplated doing it but at a
certain point you've got to you've got
to remain true to your conservative
values if you're a conservative prime
minister and that is not high taxation
I'm afraid I mean really just
yes and the accusation against Rishi
sunak was he was the chancellor that saw
the highest levels of Taxation for 70
years Kevin so you know he knows that
now is all too damaging for him but the
specifics of attacks Rises
um look to be and a lot of this has been
heralded before largely made up of
freezing tax thresholds the stealth raid
as it's known means hundreds of
thousands will pay tax for the first
time or be dragged into higher rates for
example the 45p tax rate moving from 150
000 pounds to 125 000 pounds but Sarah's
right about you know a hemorrhaging
money the telegraph also tells us the
National Audit office says the NHS has
become less productive since the
pandemic
um due to high staff sickness levels so
you know that that and the cost of
borrowing it's it's it's not a pretty
picture is it for anyone to be in charge
yeah if it complaints about tax rates so
I should have a word with the party
that's been about for the last 12 years
and as you say it's got the highest uh a
highest taxation burden as it's called
Uh since the since the 19 uh 40. I just
I personally I don't view spending
investing money in in health and
education as hemorrhaging money and
there's a there is a problem in in the
NHS certainly over agency workers and
then again I suggest Sarah shall have a
word with the parties that's been
running the NHS for the last 12 years
why they never got a proper uh Staffing
plan to get people into the NHS
to agencies but the there is there's
also a productivity problem on
unquestionably uh since covert but
that's you know it's because people are
under such strain under incredible
strain and they're exhausted and they're
worked out uh for instance we've seen a
lot of a lot of talk recently about
having hospitals fully staffed on is on
Sundays now I think that's a really good
idea but if you're shifting staff from
the other days of the week well it's not
going to be running uh at its current
level on a Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday or you have to hire even
more staff to work those days there's no
simple answer but the NHS when Jeremy
Hunt now the now the chancellor who when
he was the health secretary longest
serving Health secretary in the the
history of the NHS he imposed the
tightest Financial straight jacket on it
and those problems are still there
they're not they're not solved yet and
overall spending
we're around somewhere around the middle
just below the middle of comparable
countries okay it's not as if it was
splurging Cash on it it's just not the
case
I just think the problem I mean I agree
with you Kevin education is something
very that one should spend a lot of
money on if possible but it's more about
what you do with that money the key
thing is is that you have to make sure
these services are properly run and
properly administered and I think that's
the issue here is it's poor management
really which means that there's a lot of
interest in the system yeah and just
very quickly on energy I'll rattle
through it um Telegraph reporting uh
that Mr Hunt will also announce a
multi-billion pound plan to insulate
homes and upgrade boilers in a drive to
cut Britain's energy demands while the
guardian is saying that Millions face a
rise in their energy bills as hunt lifts
the price cap we kind of knew that was
coming suggestion is though that that
some help will continue after next April
but perhaps we can talk about that more
next time lots more to back in to the
program I have to say including the very
latest two on uh that rocket attack on
Poland extraordinary pictures there of
the Huddle at the G20
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
with me once again the Daily Mail
columnist Sarah Vine and the associate
editor at the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire
welcome back to both of you so some
extraordinary meetings underway both all
those world leaders who'd been woken up
in Bali Kevin
um those who'd been there for the G20
NATO member states meeting today too
after this rocket explosion on the wrong
side of the Border in Poland look at
that picture there and the Continuing
Story now is that uh zielinski insisting
it was Russian I mean is it is it time
to to let this go do you think for the
Ukrainian leader
I think it is look at look at that
that's uh Biden at the very front that's
Biden on the left and the back that's uh
that sunak he'll be well pleased he's
sitting there although I'm sure you like
his face in the picture but you can just
see the panic because if it had been
fired by the Russians onto a NATO member
uh you know art article uh five
Collective defense we've really raised
the state but Biden very quickly said he
thought the trajectory meant it or it
wasn't fired from Russia uh the U.S NATO
the polls themselves all say it was an
air defense missile used by the
Ukrainian zelensky is still saying no
that's not the case I think he should
let it go because I think facts and
Truth matter in Wars often the uh the
fog of war and there's confusion
difficult to get to them you
know the truth was the first casualty of
War has been around in a sane evidence
of it since uh the 19th century but
everybody else thinks it was fired by
the ukrillians it's an accident two
people are dead it's a tragedy but
zelenski one wanted that to be fired by
the Russians to try and pull NATO into
the war in a much deeper way but I think
he's just got to accept it now it was
one of his own it was an accident okay
Sarah I was one of those people who
stayed up late last night to listen to
Donald Trump uh deliver the non-surprise
announcement that he was going to stand
you know what does it say that the only
front page he's making is the Daily Star
who says an orange man vows to conquer
the red planet I mean what what are his
prospects if you look at that
I know I mean he's just a joke isn't he
I I don't know why he's doing it he's
just wasting his money out I mean his
supporters are also Bonkers as well I
don't know if you've seen any footage of
them they're all completely insane
um and even his daughter Ivanka said I
love my father very much but I'm not
going to get involved as Tyrann
um and I think she's right I I mean I I
don't know why why does he why does he
want to do it who knows it's a mystery I
can't understand it and then and also
he's done so badly I just don't you know
he literally is just throwing good money
after bad yes and I'm not sure he uses
his own money does he he uses the free
media attention which he's certainly got
back in 2016.
um but the prospect is if if more than
one candidate stands against him for the
Republican nomination Kevin you know
he'll get 35 of the vote in most Winner
Takes all states he could still be the
nominee
oh yeah it's not it's not impossible I
mean I really hope he isn't we saw the
chaos that was Unleashed last time and
he was laughed at then all the scandals
somehow bounced off of him and he became
became the president I feel if he'd
launched uh last week before the
midterms it had been a much stronger
position but we saw on his uh your
Bonkers candidates were doing
particularly badly now in some ways uh
somebody who's on the left and you know
in the state would be a Democrat voter
uh I would like him to stand because I
think python could beat him Rhonda
Santos who has many of the policy
positions of trump that doesn't have the
uh you know the same crazed uh exterior
by and large although some of the bits
some of the stunts they were sending uh
migrants uh to um refugees to Martha's
Vineyard and a little bit concerning
um
if you don't mind I'm going to cut in I
just want to get to Sarah's paper
um already worried about Christmas
turkeys you've got 10 seconds Sarah now
it's eggs
I know it's a very worrying situation
the egg situation I like eggs I mean I
mean we can probably all cut back our
consumption of eggs I mean my
cholesterol is probably not what it
should be thanks to my egg consumption
but um there's just been this awful
awful avian few it flew everywhere and
that you know that's just what's caused
the problem uh Sarah I'm gonna have to
cut you off as well I've managed to do
it to both of you I do apologize
thank you both very much indeed thank
you